good afternoon everybody
my name is Nick I am sitting here with
the mr. Ramon Russell from the MLB he is
a game designer and Community Managers
that correct that is also that is
correct
well welcome we're here playing a little
MLB the show 17 yes we are and I am
super excited because today is
officially pitchers and catchers they
are report it's baseball season thanks
Paul is back in his big final it feels
good it feels good everybody's happy and
we're super happy because we get to talk
more about the game absolutely
so right off the bat what are we looking
at here right now I am going to show you
what we've been focused on graphically
for the game this year every year
there's always a focus and in our post
mortems last year after the game
launched we were kind of saying
internally you know the stadium's in our
atmosphere look really really good the
players of maybe lagging behind a little
bit so let's focused on the players real
MLB players and specifically create a
player those are the two main areas of
focus graphically this year and so we're
looking at mr. Robinson canó here who
looks absolutely fantastic the first
thing you'll probably notice is the eyes
we started from scratch from the eyes
Patrick Hager John Ramsey and the rest
of the graphics team they ripped the old
eyeballs out and they started from
scratch the shape is better the lighting
is better on the eyes and hopefully
we've gotten rid of that will be called
ghost look where the eyes just don't
match correctly so that's really really
important so the eyes are fantastic this
year the lighting and the shadowing from
them happen on a baseball cap that's a
lot better this year and also skin tones
skin tones or are always really
important to us and with our new
lighting technology and things we've
done there the skin tones have more
depth you can see pores
just so much better and that's not just
with real players on all of these things
go on to create a player and we'll talk
about that right now
fantastic and I got to say the facial
hair is another thing that I always
notice and it's fantastic so and with
the the facial hair for real MLB players
our character team which is I think six
guys
that's like every strand of hair is
hand-painted like they hand paint at
like 750 players hair which is really
fantastic so create a player completely
revamped um we got body types the faces
the heads the eyes skin tones everything
has been changed so the only thing I
wouldn't really pay a lot of attention
to is the skin tone palette we're still
working on that
this isn't the final version of what the
skin tone palette would be like right so
last year or any other you if you were
playing wrote to the show and you'd see
the fake guys you could always tell them
how like you could pick them out they
just they look like they just look bad
this year we're hoping you won't be able
to tell who's a fake guy who's a real
guy and I'm just going to start
randomizing this guy so you can see all
the granularity we have so it's not just
the faces it's not just the skin tones
but body types is huge for so we have a
new body type called husky we also have
body model sliders so you can elongate
the spine for for guys who look like
Chris Sale really long really lanky
right you can shorten the spine we have
shoulder sliders we have we've got a
butt slide of y'all okay we have a good
slider so as I continue to randomize
this guy you can see there's so much
more granularity in the type of body
types and players that we're going - oh
we like that stache so we'll start here
looks like Jason Werth already and so
here's one of the sliders which is
collarbone and shoulder width and this
is something our fans have been asking
for for a very long time you can see
here that's much more you can do to make
this guy really look unique the next one
is arms you know he's got some guns
right now and some people figured that
out in the gameplay trailer there's like
take area those arms a lot bigger
you are correct his arms are a lot
bigger and so I'm sitting here tweaking
the sliders so for all real MOV players
they've been hand tuned we've gone in
looked at reference photos they've been
hand tuned right you can't mess with
them cuz they're real but your guy you
can do whatever you want and here's my
favorite slider the butt slider you know
you can give them a little bit of donk
or the two but you can take it away yeah
yeah the glute slider and the hip slider
so you can change this we also have
thighs
some guys have much bigger thighs than
others so you can change this around and
we can just we can hit the random
and see what we end up with heads heads
are hugely important for this year every
other MLB to show game we shipped with
17 default heads and it was great for
where we were but this year we started
from scratch
Bobby Fitzgerald Gil Garcia and our
entire graphics and character team they
created 49 brand new archetype heads and
these 49 heads were placed a 17 they're
gone and they're all based upon
different ethnicities that you see in
real life actually we have a [ __ ] a few
Caucasian American heads we have a few
african-american heads we have a few
heads that are based on Asian
territories and Dominican Republic and
Puerto Rico and those territories as
well so you'll see we just go through a
few of these you see there's much more
granularity and what you can do now with
the head shapes and we'll just randomize
it incredible custom Asian yeah and so
you see even with the randomizer we're
not getting any monsters we're getting
guys that really that look like real
players so hairstyles started hairstyles
over from scratch every hairstyle in the
game is brand new and we're going to go
to my favorite hairstyle the Oscar
gamble oh my god the front at Oscar
gamble Coco Crisp afro Sun what you know
this is also one of my favorite hair
styles here and again you can change the
color we're still working on the color
palette so that'll be tweaked and then
facial hair is also really important so
facial hair we added I think we added
about 22 new facial hair sets and what
we wanted to do was add some facial hair
sets that you would see in real life
things that people have been wearing we
got some old-school Styles like this one
is modeled like kind of the King Felix
Hernandez yeah we have one we are beards
are so much more granular now because
not everybody has a straight beard some
beards are more curly right and so now
we have those options we have a few more
unique things as you can see here so we
think people are really going to be able
to create much better looking characters
and just like last year you know you can
combine and add-on you can mix and mock
Mac some of the different beards and
whatnot to create your own style of what
you want to see in the game right and
some of these
I'll find another one have new links so
you couldn't create a guy who looked
like this in last year's game so we're
really excited about that the increased
customization is fantastic I mean the
fact that you can combine two different
beard styles to create something really
unique is and see we put a hat on this
guy and I think this looks like this
doesn't like a guy from the movie
Sixteen hopefully you feel the same way
I agree that hat customizations actually
might be my favorite part on this whole
part right again we're just randomizing
we're just going through randomizing and
these are the type of guys that you'll
see enrolled to the show and you can see
here these guys look so much better and
one more time we'll go to the eyes the
eyes were a huge focus this year and
that is create a player in a nutshell
but it's not just physical appearance
it's also personality what we've done
this year is well he's a pitcher but we
got to make this guy not be a picture of
pitcher go back to personality
animations
we've now allowed you to have the
ability to choose players homerun
sequences last year if you chose a guy
batting stance you got all of that his
home run and his home run swing but you
didn't get anything special that he had
right now if anybody has anything
special you can now choose that
celebration package and that's anything
they do on base anything to do at second
base third base or home plate so you can
have um Justin Turner's batting stance
with Ken Griffey junior homerun package
right and you can mix and match and do
whatever you want there and that is
create two player and you can pick I
noticed music as well yeah and you can
always choose your music sounds of the
show comes back we've also upgraded
sounds of show so there are more slots
and a few other things so we're going to
jump into retro mode you wanted to see
retro mode right yes I would love that
I don't got some pretty I'm yeah that's
kind of how when I grew up a lot of the
games in the arcades were you know one
button mode you're right right and
that's what when we were thinking about
the genesis of retro mode was like one
it's got to be super slim simplistic one
button so X is a swing all your pitches
are done with X
and you have three pitches we bowled all
the attributes down to fastball changeup
and slider but even though it's a
one-button quick mode all that depth is
still there you know all the animations
we've added to the game this year you'll
see them in retro mode right the
graphical change you'll see those in
retro mode the hits per nine decays per
nine home runs pronounced those are
still working behind the Train so even
though it's a one-button mode you're
still getting all of those advances from
MLB to show 17 so something we haven't
really talked about a lot is you know
you can move the batter around in the
batter's box and the pitcher can do the
same on the pitching mound this is not
just cosmetic this actually affects
plate coverage and there's some new ball
physics we saw there little bloop single
and if you don't find the ball with the
bat you're gonna miss it so even though
it's one button mode there's still that
depth there that people have come to
know and love and write over the show
and you were mentioning ball physics
right I heard there's there's new things
about you know liners up up a you know
left field line the right field line
those are will now curve yeah we have
our ball physics code has really really
been taken to the next level by Jeff
McArthur or one of the lead programmers
the way the ball feeds code used to work
was we were modeling the code and the
physics as if the round baseball were
hitting a wall which was okay
it gave us fantastic hit variety but not
the best hit variety right we were
missing a few so now with the new code
our ball physics is based on a round
ball hitting a round bat so the height
of the batter where the pitch is the
location to spin atmospheric elements
temperature all those things affect the
spin of the ball and what that does is
it gives us more hit variety like bloop
Singles Texas leaguers and especially
those slicing hits down the line where
that ball will hit the line stay fair
but it'll start the tail off and nose
you just didn't see at all in last
year's versions of game or any other
version of game so absolutely when I was
talking to Jeff and I asked I was like
so how monumental is this change I was
like give me a number like what what's
to hit variety like there's like it's
easily in the hundreds of thousands of
new hits maybe even into the million so
you're going to be playing this game ten
months in and your stay
you're going to be seeing new hit types
the ball landing in new spaces that you
write never would have seen before and
we're really excited about that because
we want people play this game too the
season's over with absolutely yeah
and I mean there's a ton of games you
know all year long and so if you're
playing franchise mode obviously you do
play in a ton so keep that unique
so it's essentially it's the ball now
reacting to hitting a round bat round
bag they finally kind of created in the
game environment yes we have some very
very talented and smart programmers we
got at C&S des des there's a perfect
example which means I'm gonna give up a
run but her big example the new ball
this time to happen
perfect example actually going to replay
and look at the hit over again which we
would do but it's not retro but I should
know that I work on this game I will I
was going to say retro mode number one
looks fantastic thank you so this camera
we created just for retro mode you can
use it in a regular version of the game
people from saying they really like this
camera but you can use it anywhere in
the game also another thing is you know
a retro mode it's old-school OSDs you
have the ball whistle during strikeouts
you can see people break the bat and all
those things are specific to retro mode
right thank you double play here nope
and I know you want to take some hacks
go ahead oh you want to go you don't we
get in oh yeah I'm gonna give up
this is a double oh it's oh that's
problem that's a problem off the IV yeah
I'm not doing so well here so that's
retro mode which we're going to jump out
of because I'm losing and we get three
conversion of the game if I was on the
controller it would be a lot worse
alright well it will let them put the
ball and play one more time
well blooper nice little blooper and
that is retro mode so here we are in a
regular for a regular game gameplays
King gameplay has always been king with
MLB the show and this year is no
different we focused on a lot of things
most importantly it was things that we
thought we were weak at so we already
talked about ball physics what we also
really want to look at was fielding
there were some situations where
shortstops the second basemen will may
be taking a little bit too much time to
throw so we have a brand new catch and
throw engine I just hit a home run
that's a double so have a brand new
catch a throw engine and we also have
this thing called humanity AI and and
what both of those things do in
conjunction is when let's say Billy
Hamilton is up at the plate the computer
knows that that's Billy Hamilton he has
a 99 speed on a ground ball if you take
your time he's going to be safe right so
because they're conscious of that
they're going to get the ball out
quicker if it's somebody let's say a
Anthony Rizzo or Miguel Cabrera who
isn't you know they're not running the
4340 right they know they'll have a
little bit more time and they'll they'll
take a pump and then throw the ball and
those things are really important
because in real baseball you'll see the
guys they know that that they'll take
their time when they need to when they
can't take their time they'll throw the
ball so the reason we need to have that
not just for game balance is for realism
so it looks real if every single time
somebody put the ball in play and they
were running a million miles down the
first base
that wouldn't be realistic you know the
baseball season is long you know but
gale Cabrera if he busted out the first
base every time he makes contact that's
gonna wear him down right if he knows
he's going to be out he's going to jog
so our betters know that and they'll jog
when they need to if they think it's
going to be a bang-bang play they know
they're going to be safe they're busting
out of there running full speed
absolutely and animations is also huge
for us every year every year we add
hundreds of animations this year it's
over a thousand and these are catches
dives double play turns we have so many
more animations out of branching from
different positions and you're going to
be seeing new animations ten months down
the line and people are that you know
they asked me on Twitter
is it really a thousand animations yes I
go into Chris Clements his office he's
the lead animator and every year I sit
down with him like okay how many new
animations do we have and he'll pull up
that excel file and we'll highlight
every single new animation and then
we'll come so when we say there's a
thousand gameplay animation you know I'm
dead serious I'm not lying now these
animations include the like team
specific celebrations for example on the
Red Sox outfield so those actually
separate all those yeah so those aren't
even in that animation code that we're
looking at but there is a lot more
player specific and teen specific
celebrations animations this year right
like we've added all of the wind dance
repeat dances that the Red Sox do we've
added a few things that Chicago Cubs do
we have a lot of stuff for the Texas
Rangers or any team that we could get
info on if they did something special
when they have a home run or double or a
rally we motion capture that and try to
put it into the game which is awesome
yeah we see some go really like special
things that are so unique to the MLB and
it's something that makes it feel more
realistic when you see it in a game like
the show yeah we need two guys to look
like they look in real life play like
they play in real life and react like
they would react in real life like
player emotion is really really
important to us yeah for sure
it's not gonna be able to get that one
also we've updated all of our pitching
meters so now we now you see we're
giving you time and feedback so this is
something that we've introduced to one
take the desk guesswork out of like ones
aren't really close to hitting the sweet
spot and two for newcomers to the game
it's a little bit easier for them to
understand okay I missed the sweet spot
I was perfect I was very early or late
kind of like the way you get feedback
from batting indeed indeed exactly so is
it just like the PCI and the swing
analysis for pitching always loved hey
words and hey what has a new stance does
actually over 350 new batting stances
and recaptured batting stances this year
Haywood has a new one I think he found a
video of him training a few months ago
took that into the motion capture
facility and that's how he got his new
stance yep see Anthony Rizal's not
wearing shades we finally fixed that
he doesn't wear shades in the summertime
I know everybody's probably going to be
most excited for probably one of the
most legendary stances in all of
baseball
the man gracing the cover of your game
yeah ken griffey jr. stance is in the
game it's him
if you've seen the vote motion capture
video you know that's him doing his
stance you get a stance you can get his
homerun package it's all there in the
game and there are so many packages you
can choose from to help you create a
player any guys that you're creating
really stand out in the crowd
so another thing I'll show is haven't
really talked about this is um you know
every year graphically you know we're
always focusing on a few things and and
playstation3 it took us about five six
years to get the graphical maturity and
that was all based on a yearly playing
like every year we worked on a different
section of the game this year is no
different you know we're now in that
third or fourth year of that plan and
the stadiums look really good now we're
moving on to the players another thing
we did was we wanted the grass to really
react like it does in real life so
Patrick and the graphics team when you
go to a real MLB game the patterns that
you see they're created by the mowing
right the grass differently and because
the grass blades are facing a different
direction the Sun hits it creates those
shadows and that's what creates that
contrast we've had that in the game for
years but it was fake what would happen
is the dark areas of the grass they were
just darker right now we're actually
using real coal to simulate what you see
in real life so now our grass blades are
just like you see in real life so as I
move the camera and the Sun changes
you'll see that the patterns will change
as well and this was a huge task
something that did not this took a long
time for them to get into the game but
it's just something else that makes the
game look a little bit more real you'll
see them change in gameplay when you're
playing and putting the ball in play
especially with stadiums like again the
Red Sox who sometimes do some wild kind
of create yeah they do some rock growl
crazy Yankee fans new Yankee fan uh-huh
that's among
what are you gonna do does the ball
itself react differently depending on
the weather
yes game yeah atmosphere temperature all
those things affect the ball whether
it's on dirt or grass those things
affect the spin hopefully we're leaving
no stone unturned
none whatsoever would you say that the
grass might have been the most
graphically challenging improvement from
the last installment uh whereas it's
Moore's I think it will air it probably
everything especially the body sliders
the body sliders the lighting on the
face the skin tones redoing create a
player was a humongous task you know our
development team is only about 80 people
now we were relatively small team for a
yearly cycle and those guys really
worked their butts off every single year
to continue to push this game to where
we eventually wanted to get right and
this year is hopefully no different it's
a nice little hit failed dive looks
super realistic and that's uh that's
game play also we've really worked on
budding bunting was a sore spot it's not
gonna be as easy as it was before if a
guy can't but it's gonna be much much
tougher for him than the guys who can oh
there's a perfect little little bloop
bloop hit that he called seeing tons of
new ball fixes even even in this quick
little interview yep yep I know I feel
like everything you've been talking
about that happens which is great
are all the old pitching kind of uh I
don't know ACA models still around like
the analog stick yeah so analog pitching
still in the game
post pitching is still there so is
classic pitching looking back schwarber
stance schwarber stance he sees and you
see his body model and his body type
it's been tuned it's been a hand tune
that looks more like he would look in
real life you could cross-reference that
with sixteen I bet you'll see a
difference also some other people picked
up on we have new catcher set up
animations so all of the catches won't
set up the same way we have a few
different styles right and that
begone that's gone that is gone but as a
foundation year it's gonna be really
awesome we think there's something for
everybody the MLB to show 17 room it
comes out March 28th go pre-order now
are there different versions when it's
released yes so we have the digital
deluxe version which is only on the
PlayStation Store we have the Hall of
Fame Edition which comes with a special
new era
5950 hat it's the only way you can get
that hat they're never releasing it
again it's in limited quantities it will
sell out that's available exclusively at
Gamestop we have the MVP Edition which
we've done in the past you can get that
digitally or from your local retailers
and that's about it
fantastic I know I'm really looking
forward to the game coming out and I'm
just looking forward to having baseball
back in my life to be honest Oh a week
so thank you so much again and keep it
right here on GameSpot for all your MLB
the show 17 news